throughout the pandemic China's
population has faced some of the
toughest restrictions in the world but
now just weeks after president XI
recommitted to the zero covert policy
there's been a dramatic shift China's
announced its loosening the rules PCR
testing is to be reduced those infected
will isolate at home rather than at
State facilities and there'll be more
freedom to travel
the further deepening of the
understanding of the virus and the
disease the reduction of the risk of the
disease the efficient supply of vaccines
and medicine and the Improvement of
emergency response and treatment
capabilities are some of the required
conditions or key elements for us to
resume the living conditions before the
outbreak happened
the announcement comes a week after
unprecedented protests across China
against the strict pandemic measures
demonstrators were angered by the deaths
of several people in an apartment fire
which they blamed on lockdown measures
the announcement reportedly triggered
some Panic buying of medicines although
many in Beijing welcomed the news
to be honest I'm quite satisfied because
it's impossible to kill this virus
completely maybe just live with it and
hope it will evolve into the common flu
if you are in the quarantine facilities
you may be more seriously infected
because there are serious cases there it
would be better if you were quarantined
at home
despite China's zero covert strategy
infections have climbed in recent weeks
the loosening of rules could have a
dramatic impact on the health of the
people and the economy in the coming
weeks Cara leg Al Jazeera